so
as promised we're going to bring up some
of the people who helped create some of
the amazing things we're going to see
tonight like that scene from frozen
uh this next person was born in wichita
kansas
and studied character animation for two
years at cal arts
give it up for calarts
ultimately teaching at the school from
1988 to 1983 he worked as a character
designer for such disney productions as
the little mermaid and the rescuers down
under before serving as animation
director on bb's kids
he made his feature directing debut with
tarzan and received his first oscar
nomination for animated feature film
surfs up please that was with
co-director ash brannon please welcome
co-director of frozen chris buck
hello chris there's a microphone there
for you
but before we start talking
so the next person i like to bring up to
talk about frozen
received her m fma in film from columbia
columbia university
before launching her career as a
screenwriter
she received her first screenplay credit
on
wreck-it ralph
kind of sweet on her
which led to her role as writer and
eventually co-director of frozen with
chris she's the first female director of
an animated film from walt disney
studios how do you like them apples
please welcome jennifer lee
i'm not done we have one more person
these people have a very important part
of movie making
they do a lot of the work
this person was the production manager
on disney's hercules
and the associate producer on treasure
planet and chicken little before serving
as producer for the princess and the
frog and winnie the pooh
he received his first nomination for
animated feature
for frozen please welcome producer peter
del becco
what are that bro
have a seat can is everyone's microphone
working i don't know yes
yes
all right so this is the terrifying part
where i have to rifle through these
notes and
well congratulations
i thought we were supposed to be the
terrified ones oh i'm terrified i'm i'm
really good at answering questions
terrible at asking them
um
first of all congratulations on topping
the box office of wreck-it ralph
oh
did not see that coming i thought i was
going to ride that top position for
quite a while and it lasted about six
months but anyway
so jennifer you and i met on wreck-it
ralph we did you sat there in the
control room with us while i changed all
your words
so why don't we start by saying by by
each of you saying like how you got
involved in this in the first place like
this this story is loosely based on the
houns christian anderson story of the
ice queen correct
it's called the snow queen the snow
queen but that's my first mistake
those of you scoring at home so
tell me chris how did you get involved
uh frozen well i i pitched it i pitched
it when i came back to the studio in
2008 and i pitched it to john lasseter
and ed catmull and um
it was an idea that uh everybody seemed
excited about it was a world that um
disney had never done for a whole
feature that's sort of this icy snowy
world
and uh and then this character of the
snow queen which is just really really
fascinating um we took some liberties
with the story
as we always do and um but yeah so
that's that's where at least my
involvement that was about five and a
half years ago so i loved how you made
the audience feel for this person who
was in
you know in opposition to what was going
on for everyone else
you didn't give her the uh you know the
snow white treatment of the evil queen
you like oh we were there i understand
that oh we did we went down there we
started that we started it interesting
yeah so do you want to we can talk about
the evolution that's where it started
and then jen came on and peter came on
and i was like no no i'm kidding it
wasn't me
you started writing on this project and
you ended up being one of the
co-directors right i was still on ralph
and this guy came in and said hey
i sat on the corner of your desk and
said hey would you even consider the
possibility of writing on frozen i went
no it was it was amazing i mean i had
connected with it write it we give notes
on each other's projects so these guys
would come in and give notes on wreck-it
ralph and we'd go in and frozen and i
was falling for it heavily particularly
when we decided to make them sisters i
was like you know i love to tell that
story so
it was it was a definite obviously and
but it was you know we didn't know quite
we kind of started over in a lot of ways
and that's where elsa was a villain when
i came on she was she was pretty bad and
it was more of like a redemption story
right um but we're like god we do good
versus evil all the time and we had just
done a bad guy wanting to be good you
know yeah and and in the original book
there's this theme that runs through it
about the power of love over negativity
or fear and we said well that's
something we haven't done
and we just made sort of honor
represents love like gerda in the book
and
and elsa represents fear kind of like
kai in the book and
it went oh it made sense do you have a
sister i do she's coming to the oscars
actually with me oh she's my outfit
you know i don't know she means that in
the best possible way no i do
you know at the end of the movie elsa i
thought that was one of the brilliant
things about the film was that really
for the
for the first time in my
experience with any film animated or not
this sense of emotional
stalemate between two
sisters
two two women characters i mean that's i
think
uh if you if that's what you brought to
this project
no no offense chris i'm sure you have a
very strong feminine side
thank you john he does i love you i love
the fact that
you know there's something very real
about that in a lot of families about
two people trying to reach each other
but they're
they're holding a position
usually based on the past
that they can't let go of and i you know
cartoons are all about metaphors and
that was a really powerful metaphor in
this film well for us that's how we knew
that was when we all got really behind
the film and the whole studio did
because we all could relate even if it
wasn't a sister but someone in your
family brothers siblings of any kinds or
any family member and that's kind of we
said oh now we found the emotional
engine we needed well as soon as we did
that found the sister thing we did a
thing called the sister summit and we
brought in all the women who wanted to
talk about their sisters at the studio
and we thought
yeah and we thought that we were going
to have to have all these questions
and we just started with so who wants to
talk about their sister and
everybody did everybody it just went
round and round around and yeah there's
this crazy myth that women's
stories are not
box office and
no matter how many success no matter how
many abba movies we have or whatever
mamma mias or
frozens we have
every three months it goes back to oh no
you know until the next ghost or the
next whatever like women's stories don't
sell
it's just it's crazy because it i think
for men and women a women's story is
really well we feel like it's a story
that hasn't been looked at well we felt
like with this one of the key was not
doing
princesses that were on some pedestal
like some iconic princesses you don't
relate to we like if you make all the
characters very real boy girl just
relatable
we think
men and women will relate to them that
it's not you know just girls or just
boys um and so we just really pushed and
used having you know kristen bell
uh
i had a quick kristen bell story i have
to tell you though
there is something that went around the
studio because there's a line she says
in the film when hans is eating krunkaka
and she goes you got it
and the layout people had slowed it down
because they were working on it and they
realized it sounds just like wreck-it
ralph you got it when it's slow and so
that's that's like the catchphrase of
the studio is and we realized so if you
slow kristen bell down about 70 percent
she sounds like john c reilly
you could fit kristen bell inside of my
body
she could work me like a puppet
so peter
how do you
what's your role in this because you
know produ people think like
producers is is a set role but in fact
on every movie i've done it's it goes
from being the rich guy who doesn't know
anything about movies
to the person who's actually doing all
of the work and and every layer in
between there so
i'm especially interested in how you
synthesized the creative type team
writing the animators the director and
the songwriters who are not in los
angeles is that correct that's right
well first of all let me set the record
straight i'm not the rich guy
not yet baby yeah
uh i mean i always view my job it's to
understand the movie that the directors
want to make and help them get it up on
the screen and that takes varying forms
it can be helping choose the staff
that's going to be hired to surround
them it could be working with them in
the story room or an editorial or you
know the casting of the movie
but it's also to kind of shelter in a
way create a safe environment for them
to do what they do best and that's be
creative so uh my role is also to take
on you know the marketing uh side of it
the the
budget part of the movie interfacing
with the studio more to allow for that
creativity to to protecting us from that
and as far as bobby kristen goes
we had the good fortune of working with
them uh earlier on winnie the pooh so i
was very familiar with them and we
actually went to new york
and saw a book of mormon saw avenue q
and it was at that point i think chris
uh said that that would be a great match
for this film yeah book amara would be
perfect for a disney movie
but could you make it a little more edgy
i think where you're going
go edge here
well that's cool
i could listen to you guys talk all
night in fact i would prefer that you
talked on that
so i just say one of your i i i love all
your stuff but one of the my favorite
roles that you did was bigfoot
the strawberry river i don't know what
you're talking about sasquatch is real
and also about
seven percent of the audience knows who
you're talking about so it's okay sorry
yeah
so i'm curious
thank you for pointing out
how you synthesized everything peter
how am i doing okay so far sorry let's
have my back turn to you guys
um
so i'm curious in my notes i was given
uh i was told that
as you progress with the story
and and hashing out the script and i'm
fascinated by how all that comes
together even having been through it
myself it's this vast mystery i would go
for these q and a's with the animators
there'll be a hundred people in the room
and what did these 30 people do oh they
work the mouth like
what
the mouth my mouth
anyway so it's a total mystery to me
which i hope some of these mysteries
would be solved but one of them was like
how how the story was actually
influenced by what this
these songwriters are doing and they're
very talented people obviously from the
credits that you mentioned um
so what how did that play out you know
yeah did you give them notes and were
they meant to do it or did was it a back
and forth it was bad i mean it was like
a chicken and egg we we outlined
together and you'd kind of go maybe a
song here and the key you know is that
the most emotional moments will be songs
and so then i'd start writing and they'd
get pages and we'd start playing they
might do a demo of a song and then i'll
have to rewrite and i mean let it go
changed everything um that was when we
really found elsa and i rewrote
everything around it because we were
willing to support it so we met with him
every morning via video conference and
um we have we had a burton ernie um
poster hanging above the video uh
bernie was supposed to be like it's we
have you guys will know some of them you
put characters up there that might
remind you of our characters so bert and
ernie were anna and elsa
when they were little and then but but
they kept wondering like which one
they kept wondering which one what was
you know bobby which was chris and we
never told them but we know um
but yeah we did it every and it was a 14
months every day until we got the final
song i think of back and forth writing
i have this image in my head maybe
because i just saw saving mr banks where
it's this team of people sitting at a
piano all the time like how about this
one mr disney
i mean
i saw that movie and i was like i want
to work at disney all the time i want to
be like those guys that horse around on
the piano
it is kind of like that i mean they're
just the video conference but bobby be
like we're thinking a little
and then kristen would just say i've got
some you know lyrics and playing with
and start singing to us and sometimes
they were out in the studio working with
us like want to build a snowman was
bobby you know sitting at a piano and us
working on it for a whole day together
so they did do that but you know it
wasn't we weren't all jazzy dressed and
stuff
and one of you wasn't a horrible
curmudgeon like that woman
um
god lover
uh
i forgot what i was gonna say now
um
i want to thank you this is not really a
question it's a comment because you know
having done a big movie musical that was
nominated for an academy award that won
many academy awards
at that time they everyone said oh it's
the rebirth of the musical and then no
more live-action movies about that were
musicals like and this thing keeps
in the movie world seems to keep dying
like some someone will do something and
it'll be successful and then nothing for
years but i have to say like this idea
that audiences won't accept suddenly
breaking into song it's [ __ ]
i mean look at all the amazing animated
films those are that's a classic musical
structure the way that you know what
that old
phrase like when you can no longer speak
what you have to say you sing or when
your heart needs to speak it sings you
know
so thank you for that thank you for
keeping that alive you're welcome no
people people think that it was
the studio's idea to do another musical
and it really does come down to the
directors and we wanted to do another
musical so you're welcome very cool
and i i can already tell what's going to
happen it is going to become a live
stage show right
chris what about you know one
fascinating thing about watching the
movie was your treatment like you
mentioned it's the first time disney's
ever done a film that was this frosty
let's say
i was fascinated by the all the
geometric rules of how ice behaves
did you do a lot of research on that i
heard you went to see that ice hotel yes
the ice hotel in fact we're going back
in just a week uh to the ice are you are
you guys a couple now
you're going to canoodle in the ice
hotel
suddenly not so frozen
no let's just say he's afraid to stay at
the ice hotel so i no i did not stay
there last time no don't worry no no
rumors i have to say that sounds like a
terrible night of sleep to me
where am i going to plug in my sleep
apnea machine
in an ice outlet like
so yes we did but well we we did we had
other i can't top this we had other
experts um
uh there was a guy called dr snow who
lives in pasadena like the cold miser
from yes
dr snow
you got it um and he creates snowflakes
in his house or whatever in his freezer
so he came in and showed us how
snowflakes are created so even elsa's
palace as you saw is all sort of based
on that snowflake shape so we followed
that yes we did a lot of research uh but
and we didn't get to there was a trip to
norway that we did not get to go to
because we were working on the story so
who went
thanks mike giamo our brilliant art
director and uh and his artistic team
yes
we didn't get to go to norway on
wreck-it ralph we got to like make cars
out of candy in the office
like the chop shop in glendale
and so there's a so the sort of look of
the film i suppose it would be better to
ask the art director some of the people
you mentioned but i'll ask you since
you're here chris
you um
you used a lot of north
norse imagery and norseman mythology and
that kind of thing can you talk a little
bit about i mean it doesn't it's we're
not saying it takes place in norway but
we use a lot of the uh design elements
they have their um these beautiful stave
churches of course the fjords and then
there's this other folk art that they do
called rose mauling
which
is this you know very decorative kind of
thing and we put it in the costumes and
the the architecture so there were quite
a few things that we got there but i
think the greatest thing that mike mike
really added to it mike has a beautiful
eye for color and design if you guys
know mike jama but what is great is
mike's never done a cg movie this was
his first one he's always done uh
hand-drawn and so he brought that
sensibility of really pushing shapes he
brought that to cg and and i think
that's why it looks so kind of
spectacular i have an idea
let's meet some of the makers of the
croods
this first person was born in colorado
there's one person from colorado here
and at the age of 10 was drawn to
animation when he saw ward kimball's
three caballeros sequence on tv's the
wonderful world of disney
he majored in character animation at cal
arts we already clapped for them
graduating in 1984 and joined walt
disney feature animation in 1987 which
is when i graduated from college fyi
in case you were feeling old
um
he was the first person hired for their
br brand new visual development
department
with this cool thing called computers i
would imagine at the time
he made his feature directing debut
co-directing with dean de blas de
boulais
de bois de bla bla
on lilo and stitch
and that earned him his first oscar
nomination for animated feature film
he received his second nomination for
how to train your dragon
and his third for this film the croods
please welcome chris sanders
hi chris welcome
there's a microphone there
so we'll get everyone else up here this
next person began his film career as a
screenwriter
and his first credit was 1998's quest
for camelot
followed it up with the live-action
racing stripes which he wrote and
co-produced
he made his feature directing debut with
the 2008 animated feature space
chimps and
began developing the crudes in 2005
as a stop motion feature with actor
writer john cleese
ultimately writing and directing the
film in partnership with chris sanders
earning his first oscar nomination for
animated feature please welcome kirk
d'amico
hello kirk
welcome
you don't have to shake hands you
already know each other
okay that's good
and
finally the last person on the crude
team that we're going to bring up
although as all of you may know
hundreds of people behind these movies
this person was an executive producer at
the jim henson company on such films as
a muppets from space
yeah
and five children and it
before joining dreamworks animation in
2005 along with helping develop such
films as puss and boots
shrek forever after and rise of the
guardians
she was the executive producer on how to
train your dragon please welcome
christine belson the producer of the
croods
enchante
practicing my french for our later
guests
so congratulations
thank you
should we start with that same boring
junket question that you've probably
answered a thousand times which is how
you got
involved and this first of all i want to
say
thank you for making a film about my
people
when you have a brow like this
you don't get a lot of representations
in popular culture so thank you
i'm actually on the paleo diet
right now
anyway so
this
this was first developed in 2005 as a
stop motion feature for aardman you know
the guys that made wallace and grommet
and enough about them it's about these
guys right now
and dreamworks
entitled crude awakening
which i think is a better title first of
all
i love a good pun
so kirk you and john cleese were running
it together was that a nightmare is that
why it didn't come together it's like a
fleet
he's just not funny so it was really
i had to do all the work
this is time to be done with it now
actually when we first started doing it
it was meant to be a stop-motion film so
it was a different film um in the sense
that you're making a movie with the
scope of you know three or four sets
obviously we couldn't have told the
story we told here and um what happened
was just ardman and dreamworks stopped
working together they went off their
separate ways and there was a divorce
and jeffrey got this child in the
divorce um he and when chris came over
from disney in 2007 it was the one
picture he saw that was still up that he
was interested in and that's when he and
i started working on it
cool
so chris
he's sorry it's very
i'm tap dancing as fast as i can this
time
chris you moved to dreamworks from
disney in 2007
i know i just said that
i'm reiterating what you just said
because when an actor says it you see
people hear it for the first time
that's why animators don't do the voices
and cartoons
so chris
you moved to dreamworks
from disney
so uh
was there
a reason did
are you stolen away
it's gonna get uncomfortable here
tonight i like this part this is better
because i know there's some [ __ ]
infighting goes on between these studios
and i'm here to talk about it
no no you know i um i just uh it was
time to try something different uh went
over to dreamworks and it was my first
uh ever cg film and i had i had grown up
with traditional animation and i was
really grateful to have written and
directed on lilo and stitch which was a
traditionally animated film and they
actually asked us at that time do you
want to do this in cg or do you want to
do it in traditional i thought at that
point i don't think the technology was
up to the task of making those sorts of
characters look
comfortable to watch you know so uh so i
waited until i came over to work on at
dreamworks and um and uh i was on crudes
for about a year and they came in one
day and and uh they called me up to the
office and they said so chris how's it
been going and i thought i said good
good he said so it's been a a good run
and i thought oh my gosh i'm being fired
i've only been here a year and this is
it and they said well do you want to go
and now that we're changing things on
how to train your dragon do you want to
come over and work on that i said yeah
and i said immediately yes i just had a
vibe that i wanted to do it so i um i
went into that and that was for me my
crash course in all things cg and i have
to say that i really i love traditional
animation and i love cg i think they
both have their own strengths so i was
very grateful to actually be thrown into
the middle of that and learn it all so
quickly
and it was fantastic so uh yeah it was a
good move um that's one of those kind of
stunning things about about this film is
the 3d
look of it you know like i i watch all
the films this year um
leading up to this thing of course and
um
that's i thought like i wonder how much
more work
is involved
to put something into three dimensions
like that is that three times the amount
of work
these are the idiot questions now that i
come up on my
no that's on my own that's a good
question there are some things in both
there there are strengths of both
traditional and and and uh in cg it
takes so much longer to build a cg
character about a year to to to build
the outside to rig it to put the
surfaces on and to test it and then
rebuild it and stuff so about a year to
build one of those as opposed to a a
traditionally animated character which
you could just draw very very quickly
and it takes a little bit longer to
clean it up but once that cg character
is built you can take it out of its
little
virtual garage and actually animate it
very quickly and we can do things um at
the last minute in cg that we could we
couldn't do in traditional so so what's
your opinion about when i was at disney
working at wreck-it ralph i said oh i
want to go in and kind of give you guys
motion studies you can videotape me and
maybe ralph could move like that and i
was like you know like that capture
thing and they were like capture
please
that's not animation
that's puppetry or something i know they
had a really snobby attitude about
capture
they did not want me with ping-pong
balls all over my body
what's your opinion about that
well you know that's interesting we
we have a motion capture stage but we
don't use it for animation we actually
use it to go down and work with the
animators um we do two things at once
we'll work with the animators on the
scene and it's actually turned out to be
very very very valuable because um we
use it to help us with our layout stage
which if you're out there and you do
this you don't know what that means um
it's blocking from it's blocking for the
camera but the thing that turned out to
be really really valuable about that
stage is spending time we close the
doors we sit there for an entire day
with the animators all playing the roles
that they're going to play they're going
to animate those roles we spend hours
and hours just running through the scene
and again again and we discover so many
things and we invent so many things on
the spot so it's actually turned out to
be an amazing just study
of the scene
um and i highly recommend it it's pretty
pretty good but the but the video
reference like you minus the ping-pong
balls right like just the video
reference of you acting we loved that
with our actors and like emma stone in
particular you guys always wanted the
animators to study her really closely
because you would always say she's like
an animated character and yeah we always
videotape them while they
while they do the voice during the
recording session we record it and we
have a white officer that's really you
know for the neck up you know right yeah
when they're when you're talking you do
a little bit of movement but you're
restricted because of the microphone
yeah that's true it's very cool to hear
that you have the actors come in because
i think the more actors do that the
richer it gets right yeah and the real
goal is to get the actors together which
is sometimes difficult to do in the old
days in animation you didn't do that
because you didn't want the dialogue
stepping on each other but in the good
new days that that's totally cool
because that's how dialogue actually
sounds and it allows improv to exist
exactly yeah
um so i'm noticing a trend with these
teams of people where the writer worms
their way into directing
now is that just something you get your
lawyers on kirk or
wait a minute or just
suddenly become like wait a minute like
why am i wait when jennifer was here
nobody was calling what's going on those
aren't my films no right forgot all
right i just had to make sure that okay
good
okay next time let's get nick cage
anyway um so no you don't have honestly
this is what happened i was working as a
writer and you know in writing an
animation you're in the editorial you're
as as you know with jennifer she was in
your in recording sessions we're very
much part of that and so um most of the
writing
you know animation is really funny
because even directing it's a little bit
of writing a little bit little bit of
acting a little bit of storyboarding you
do everything together everybody comes
together so the one thing that the
writer does and what chris and i do
because we actually we write we're
directors who write our own scripts um
our main goal is to go
unlike a live action film where you have
300 people or 200 people on the crew
they're all there at the same time our
world they're in different buildings
they're in different floors so we run
around from floor to floor be like run
from camera and tell them this is what
they just did in acting oh this is what
they just did in art department this is
where we have to go so we're constantly
like the you know
there's no real script at any given time
it's just what's in our head and we're
working off of that because it's
changing it's so fluid so i think that
that's why um you know for us it makes
it really good because we can just get
an idea and run in to the storyboard
artist and start working with them and
we just hand it over i was just teasing
you about being thinking about that
well i remember very clearly when chris
it was you who called jane and i my
producer other producer on the film and
said kirk is doing everything he's
functioning as my partner
we should official we should make that
official we are we are doing all the
creative decisions let us coordinate
cool i think it's really cool actually i
and i commend you for doing it chris
walt disney could have done that a
little bit more himself i think back in
the day
share credit with other people but
wow
you know he's a great man but
he wanted his name at the top and that
that would be it
i'm never going to work yeah there you
go i was going to say
pretty much pretty much with that
welcome to dreamworks
the disney secret police are taking
notes
so christine the producer is always
always responsible for for everything
for the larger impacts of things when
you know when something becomes
scandalous or you know people don't like
it they first personally hit as the
producer um probably because you're
signing the checks or whatever but
so in this movie you bring to life the
fictitious
crude
crude cuss oh the credaceous credentials
sorry yeah
for the screen now
what about all those children that are
going to school asking to learn about
the credaceous era
all right do you feel like you're kind
of in there with the you know
the darwin deniers and
those people faith faith-based science
are you a proponent of faith-based
science
we found that even the five-year-olds
understood that this was utterly
fictitious and there was never any
confusion from anyone honestly
that's good to hear just avoiding the
topic of evolution as much as possible
yeah
well don't be afraid it's like anyone
with a brain knows what
really happens with evolution
so what about you know like my mostly
what i know about prehistoric times
does not come from the classroom or
science at all comes from fred
flintstone and barney rubble
that's right
exactly
and i think it's part of the big part of
the appeal of your film in the first
place was that that
that was the path
forged for you by by those guys did you
consciously make an effort to say
all right we're not going to serve
brontosaurus ribs
or you know
was that something you thought about
like not repeating those guys we did we
talked a lot about what era we should
set this in and we ultimately decided
it's going to be you know after the
dinosaurs and stuff like that it's going
to be an all mammal kind of world um we
had a lot of discussions about where we
were going to place it in the timeline
and uh ultimately decided on this
invented time period that we would
populate with fanciful animals and uh
and to do that we went to our our design
designers and we started talking about
like we need a different sort of
creature to live in this world we want
people to understand that it's planet
earth but it's a unique time period and
uh one of our artists shane pragma he
did this this drawing where he had taken
two familiar creatures and he combined
them into one and we thought you know
that's a great uh uh controlling idea
for the film is that it'll be creatures
that if you look the theory being
the conceit being if you went backwards
in time creatures were combined and that
maybe as time rolled forward they either
disappeared or they separated into
unique creatures and so that was our
first little foothold into this unique
era that we created for the film
cool
i want to thank you as a fan of
fireworks for for showing that the first
thing man did when he
received the gift of fire was make
fireworks basically burn everything down
yeah
not warm ourselves or cook the meat it's
like let's make fireworks that i mean i
love fireworks so
i appreciated that
i guess i am a caveman
so along with all the comedy and action
there's a strong emotional element in
the film's portrayal of family life
there's some real [ __ ] that goes down
between
the family
vodka is hitting me right about now that
was the marketing tag line real [ __ ]
goes down
so how did you go about balancing it
because that's that's one of the
trickiest things about doing things that
need to be funny they need to be
exciting
but they need to be real at the same
time was that something that that
happened over the course of the script
development or was it on the fly like
you know that's that's the i think one
of our honestly that was the biggest
thing we do as directors is to manage
that tone and to make sure that those
dials are set between the emotional
parts and and the comedic parts and
there are certain areas for us that we
were going to take even just because we
know most of our audiences are children
you know they're kids and so there's
places we have in this film that are
pretty dark and there's not a lot of
light there's fire and there's people
running and to know that there is that
joke on the other edge to give that
levity and that would be the biggest
laughs you know and that's where it
comes from and have that balance because
we wanted it to feel like a real family
and this was like the first dreamworks
family film actually with a whole family
the mother's alive a grandmother's a lot
yeah and with that grandmother takes a
beating though
as well they should but you know the the
thing is is that i think that if you
you're frail creatures in my world
but i think what we want to do is like
have that kind of fun on there but
really get to that thing and what we
designed to do is to start the movie in
a very broad the more comedic place and
end up in a more emotional place that
was part of the design yeah we knew that
i think going into a caveman film we had
this little list of universal caveman
expectations and we we actually within a
few works weeks of working on the story
we knew we knew this was going to a very
heavy place and uh because we just we
took a look at the story from caveman's
point of view and we realized this is a
story about like the meaning of life
like grug the dad he does everything he
can to keep his family safe and that
means keeping them in the dark in a cave
because his one and only job is to keep
them alive but is that really living and
so by the end of the film he actually is
throwing his family into the unknown
having learned that that life is risk
and so it was a really huge and very
very heavy theme so we thought all right
we're gonna we're gonna come in as funny
as we can and do this really ridiculous
like this hunt sequence where we see
like we set the first of all we're gonna
set the dials as to how resilient and
how fast and how strong these guys are
so people understand um all that um but
then we know that we are going to um
just hit all these particular points we
said okay cavemen we need a volcano we
need lava we need we need like giant
animals and tusks and we had all these
different things we wanted to check off
the list so that anybody that sees a
caveman filming oh i saw i saw all the
cavemen things i wanted to see they were
all there except brontosaurus except
that we didn't know that
that's true that's what the sequel there
you go yeah so we hit all these things
and we got through them and it was
really neat because we were i think we
we pulled into people we pulled people
in
and um
hopefully they didn't see i think how
heavy this was going to be and we didn't
see that show them that it was coming
so that it would be i think more
resonant when it came which i think
worked out really well so um yeah so
yeah it was it's always
a punch in the gut when like a really
over-the-top
ralph kramer kind of guy gets
sentimental
it's a beautiful thing you guys co-wrote
this film song yeah
shine your way yeah
do they have a piano at dreamworks so
people sit around go la la la la la
is that how that works just like in
saving mr banks
but with jeffrey katzenberg the
curmudgeon
now i have to find somewhere else to
work
or together as soon as i say katzenberg
no one wants to talk
do you see that the hush comes over
there no i give that credit to kirk
because we we knew we needed a song for
this one little bit and we weren't
really sure who should go first or what
who who we should approach and one day
kirk said you know what we'll do it and
we sat down and we started writing down
thematic lyrics and things like that and
then we called the balance of esther and
we asked him if he wanted to help out
and he said great we flew up to his
house we spent a day in his studio and
we just we wrote the song together it
was it was amazing uh
yeah the thing that you said around
really the piano piano we actually did
yeah we played it but the thing we
didn't show folk
but you see like in that clip um the one
thing and you see from the great musical
number four i mean music is we don't
have musical in the sense of anyone
singing but we built little homes for
the music in this movie very early on
alan silvestri was watching storyboards
with us [ __ ] four years ago you know
it's not like we just give him a film
and you go please squirt we're done you
know like traditionally he came in and
he was really a writer with us and we'd
be like here's a moment we want this dad
to paint this picture of this family and
we need this to resonate and he laid
those themes in as you would right from
the beginning so when we asked him hey
here's what we want to do he's like all
right we'll put these themes through and
i think that was the coolest part of
working with a composer and animation is
he's really in there so much you know
pre earlier than you would be in live
action he really
taught me one i think one of my my most
important storytelling lessons when we
were working on lilo and stitch there
was a moment in the film where stitch
went from bad to good and we we never
really put it up on screen and um we
avoided that scene and later on when he
was looking at the reels he said hey
where's that moment where you know he
goes from about a good and i said oh
well we really we didn't know how to
write it exactly so we left it out and
we're still working on how we're going
to do it and he said put it on screen
and i'll do it and i realized oh my gosh
i'd forgotten completely that music is
the greatest storytelling tool you have
and sure enough we just have a moment
where stitch is on screen the music
shifts and you know that he changed and
from then on how to train your dragon
and croods i've always built homes and
we both are big proponents of this
building little houses for music where
the biggest story turns are going to
occur and we know that you know we'll
let music doing do the talking in those
little parts
so
i'm going to bring up some of the team
that made despicable me 2 now
this person comes from a background in
comic art having worked for marvel and
dc comics from 1994 to 2000
at blue sky studio's 20th century fox
animation he worked as a story artist on
several features including robots
ice age the meltdown and dr seuss's
horton hears a who
and in 2007 he conceived wrote and
storyboarded the ice age spin-off no
time for nuts
just love saying that no time for nuts
which earned him an oscar nomination for
animated short film
he directed
yes
feel free to cloud
he directed despicable me and dr seuss's
the lorax and received his first oscar
nomination for animated feature film for
despicable me 2 which he directed with
pierre coffon
please welcome co-director chris renau
hello chris
welcome
oh it's all fun and games while you're
in the audience huh
now you're up here in the hot lights
with me
so this next person i'm going to bring
up who helped make despicable me 2
studied cinema at paris sorbonne
university between 1985 and 1988
he moved to england and worked for one
year as a junior animator at ambulation
steven spielberg's animation studio
returning to france he worked as an
animator and an animation director on
such companies as
x machina
wanda productions and passion pictures
specializing in commercials before
directing the features
and here's the hard part
le toisoi
magnifique right thank you
and he also co-directed with chris
renaud despicable me please welcome
co-director pierre coffon
enchante
did i get your last name right call
phong
you can say coffin i i i would
understand i did not want to say coffin
i thought it would be a big faux pas
it's spelled like coffin call fall
french always have a way of dressing up
things that sound bad
this next person was the he's the
producer of despicable me 2 he or one of
them he was the president of dawn steel
pictures before serving for 13 years as
an executive at 20th century fox where
he became founding president of 20th
century fox animation
did quite well i understand after his
founding performing executive producer
duties on robots and the first two ice
age films he is the founder and ceo of
illumination entertainment which in
partnership with universal has produced
despicable despicable me
hop
dr seuss is the lorax and despicable me
2 which earned him his first oscar
nomination for animated feature film
please welcome producer chris
meledandri
welcome sir
well here we are
i was wondering how you were going to
take this to the
wherever it needed to go
after that first film oh
we were wondering the first one that's a
tough thing doing a sequel
it's not for the weak of heart
it's something whenever when a movie is
a success it's something everyone wants
to do and then they try to do it and
like oh never mind
it'll never be as good as the first one
i just have to read this
the first part of the synopsis
of this movie
which i got from wikipedia
imagine you've paid for the first
despicable me it's done quite well
delightful movie and then one of these
characters comes in and says this is
what the next one's going to be
a secret laboratory near the arctic
circle is stolen by a mysterious vehicle
using a giant magnet the anti-villain
league tries to recruit former
supervillain gru not a devoted father to
margot edith and agnes to find out which
evil person stole the lab which
contained a powerful mutagen known as
px41 which can make indestructible and
extremely aggressive monsters out of
living organisms they ask gru because he
being an ex-villain knows how villains
work but gru refuses to help saying he's
a legitimate businessman now then guru
learns that dr nefaro nefario his
friends
you see what i mean
and i haven't even got to the
diving in with a shark into the center
of an active volcano park
i guess when something's really good it
makes it easier to pitch the next
installment how did that go for you
it's like where's the one-line pitch
you're right
yeah i would have been like
or whatever the first one was good do
your best
i want to be surprised at the premiere
that's why i'm not an executive
so how did that go how i mean was it a
struggle getting figuring out like where
to go because
it was so warm and fuzzy at the end of
that last one it's like how do you do
how do you continue the warm and fuzzy
but yeah
i think i think some of our biggest that
sounded like some of our story meetings
that wikipedia
description um no i think the biggest
problem with a sequel is yeah we ended
that in a very finite way and that grew
was you know no longer a villain i think
we talked about it briefly you know
would he continue in the second film but
it felt like he'd left that behind in a
very definite way
so how do we knowing that you know the
high concept of the first film was
making a movie about a villain and part
of that is his attitude um so how do we
find ways to maintain that attitude if
he's not a villain anymore so um you
know some of the things like we dealt
with you know we're all all have
children so it's like what one of the
first things we talked about was you
know what's the next phase of parenthood
for gru and how can that frustrate him
and so what ways we found his uh for his
personality to emerge were
putting him against things like you know
a new partner who's very you know bubbly
and positive
or his oldest daughter dating a boy who
he hates you know putting him against
things that would allow his personality
from the first film to emerge and i love
how you kind of kept his the fact that
he's a villain that's kind of like he's
a carpenter well he's a villain it's
like
he doesn't have to continue to do bad
things but that's still who he is a
villain i love that conceit that that
that's that's a job for a lot of people
like
yeah
that was kind of the hype part of the
high concept too was like you know uh we
used to use as a as a one-liner like
what if darth vader had to adopt three
little and take care of three little
girls you know it's like darth vader's
got to go home take off the helmet and
take care of his kids you know so it was
that that's part of the idea is like
what's the everyday life of a super
villain
so
how did you hook up with this french
fellow here
well
i found him um
i didn't want to come no
he was he was a tough sell but when i i
started this company as you mentioned
about seven years ago when i started the
company
um there were a number of people who i
knew that i wanted to work with after
having been at fox one of them was chris
renau we had worked together at fox blue
sky our writers cinco paul kendario and
designers and but i had not thought
about where we were going to be able to
make the film you know and we started to
develop
the first despicable me
um and uh but i soon realized that it
was so competitive for animation talent
the united states
that i wasn't going to be able to
attract 2 300 really world-class artists
in california or virtually anywhere in
the united states because i was a
start-up
so you found a starving frenchman
so adam for cheap but if you
one of the great
it's actually not so much of a secret
but there are just wonderfully gifted
french artists working in animation as
we'll soon see later in our program in
addition to this fine gentleman here
tonight
so um
so in looking for
another place where we could gather that
number of great artists
it led me to paris and i looked at a
number of small companies there and
wandered into one
which is was called mcguff and
and they started showing me some of
pierre's work and after about five or
ten minutes
i was completely hooked and um and then
went out and tried to convince him to
join our group and introduce these two
guys and
and and we ended up convincing him
well congratulations
did you like
ply him with
he tried a lot of stuff
so pierre you're currently developing a
spin-off film on these lovable
yellow creatures the minions
with sandra bullock and john hamm what
am i chop liver
i'm just wrecking ralph for the rest of
my life no
tell tell me tell me about that like
you're already doing a spin-off from so
i would assume if this movie's done so
well you do you'll do a third
installment of this and then in addition
these guys are going off like
can you tell us anything about that sure
well we had this idea that that
that sort of uh lingered from i'm sorry
for my english because it's getting
bumpy especially much better than my
french but believe me well it's that
drinking and then not eating it's not
helping so
but but it it is uh like we had this
idea like on the first two movies where
we sort of
always wondered about a sequence where
we we would show the minions being
created somehow but like out of an egg
or or it was like some sort of a
deduction of our contraption
and then we always ended up like on the
first movie and on the second one like
removing that sequence from from those
movies and luckily we
lucky for us that we did because
we started talking about like the
eventuality of making a
a movie just with the minions and and we
found our way in luckily just because we
hadn't done all these
this myth about the minions being
you know genetically engineered so
so that helped us a great deal and then
the the first basically we go we're
going off a comp set concept where the
minions have always existed even as like
little single cell creatures and then we
we go off from that and and and have
them
uh we create this principle where the
the minions
in whichever form are have
always wanted to work for the most evil
character of their time and so we see
them in time
uh like working for like tyrannosaur and
dracula and all these like
fictionists or real characters that
that's the first ten minutes i won't
like i'll be fired if i see more but
i think i think that sounds like an
homage to animators
these minions that work for the most
evil people in the entertainment
industry
often uncredited
working in a cellular-like structure
autonomous yet slaves
that was a joke for the animators in the
audience
i know uh
that is
it is kind of a fascinating way that
animation works you know there's
i think you guys would even acknowledge
i think any of the directors here
tonight would acknowledge that you're
kind of marshaling this enormous army
and there's no way that a single person
can really
maintain control like at least my
experience was
you're fielding all kinds of ideas being
generated like minute by minute you know
so how what's that like like
do you
how often do you find yourself saying no
no come back this way come back this way
or or do you use kind of an unfettered
approach like let's just go crazy or i i
think it depends on on what phase you're
in but i think that uh you can there are
sometimes you know people will you know
go over here a story artist or something
and you have to bring it back but i do
think for for me personally anyway part
of the philosophy is hoping to find an
idea better than yours you know if you
if you say something to a story artist
or an animator uh you can sometimes give
a specific idea or sometimes you're like
well this doesn't work how do we make it
better you really want something that
almost surprises you to come back i mean
you're right you have this super
talented army behind you and i think any
animation director is the benefit of
benefits from great ideas from every
corner of the room and you just hope
they're better than what you originally
thought of how how does that relate in
terms of what the actors bring like when
they come in to record the voice because
i always wonder like
uh you know i was encouraged a lot when
i was working on on record ralph to
bring in a lot of stuff and then i
thought like at a certain point they're
going to start to say like no more ideas
we've already drawn that scene like like
how much flexibility do you try to keep
with the actors and
we actually try to keep quite a lot
because we record you know before it
gets hard to make changes typically you
know which is animation so you know
we'll come in i mean a perfect example
for our films is steve carell you know
we came in and we knew
you know he had had the thought we
discussed with him a little bit about
the the potential of doing an accent for
the character
great accent yeah which i mean so we
didn't know what it would be you know we
had this thought so we went we had some
you know the pages and we started
playing with it and he actually did a
few ideas uh but i think very quickly
you know started to zero in on what this
would would be and then i think now of
course he's so particularly with when we
started on the sequel he knows it so
well you know i think like any actor
well in the first film there's an
element of discovery which can sometimes
you know it needs to be shaped a little
bit so sometimes we'll re-record and say
oh you know this needs to be stronger
here just because part of it is
discovery but now he's so comfortable in
the character
you don't really go through that anymore
it's just he knows it you know inside
and out yeah it's a really pleasurable
day at work for an actor i have to say i
can't speak for everybody but i know
that the length of time that you get to
work on things how intimate your
friendships get with the people that
you're working with and the fact like i
mean record ralph was the longest job
i've ever had in my whole life
well that doesn't say much for my
reliability as an employee but
um so in in my notes i was given here
it says the original idea for despicable
me came from an animator named sergio
pablos
is that true or is that just some note
that is made up
no it's true sergio pablo's um is a
spanish animator who had worked at
disney and then he moved back to spain
and started a small animation studio
there and shortly after um our starting
illumination
he came to see me and uh
he had about four different ideas and
and what was wonderful about what the
best pitch i've ever had which is
um he pitched an imagery you know pitch
with imagery and
he uh
he had the very core story of this
villain who ends up adopting three
little girls and to commit a crime and
through the process
ends up
finding love for the first time and
there are actual scenes in the first
movie that come right out of
um some of the drawings the 16 or 18
drawings he pitched uh the very first
time of course all the character design
i mean the the story in the movie has
changed dramatically from design and you
know and and and many facets of
storytelling but the very core and the
heart of it was in sergio's pitch
and is is he still alive and
so i don't know anything about him so
is he still someone you communicate with
about the general direction or was he
just an
inspiration and then you guys moved on
and he he worked with us um he worked
with us on the first film um we used um
his team in spain for a lot of the early
storyboarding
as to contribute to that
um and
and he
he's somebody that we you know still
communicate with and talk to about new
projects but he he wasn't directly
involved in the and the sequel
so
were there any things that you guys
were not able to do in the first one
that you were when it came time to do
the sequel you're like finally
a lipstick taser or whatever you know
i i i think for us a lot of it had to do
is which may be boring a lot of the
technical things um well there's lots of
technical boring people out here so
please
well i mean that's right
that's right developing fur shaders no
um so for us because you know when we
were coming to and pierre and i were
working together for the first time we
were coming to what was then mcguff
it really was you know just sort of the
the pipeline had been used to create one
film previously but uh for us it was
like making the pipeline work and sort
of making decisions based on the amount
of time we had a lot of what we did
initially um was were policing mistakes
you know a jacket you know sleeve would
pop off or something like that and so it
was really just trying to find out what
our our system was going to be to make
to make the movie so for us
you know the the fluidity that we have
now over the course of what's been three
movies now and you know minions with
hair and you know huge crowds of minions
and the way we can animate them um you
know all that's very exciting for us
because you know as we were building the
the the factory um you know we had a lot
of
glitches to get through well it's a real
amazing accomplishment it's one of the
films that we're looking at tonight that
i feel like is
is in the straddles this place between
you know traditional flat animation and
the 3d look of like the croods you guys
there's a 3d element there's a lot of
finished detail all the way around the
characters but it still looks like
a traditional animation so um anyway
no that's something pierre and i
actually both try to strive for and our
designer uh eric gion is a big element
of that is a very simple uh graphic uh
sensibility and i think obviously the
minions you know really i mean they're
basically tic tacs with a goggle put on
them so you know they really typify that
approach it must be it must be so
satisfying like when you make a film
because let's face it anytime you make
any film you really got to think of it
as a one-off you know you're not going
to there's a good chance you're not
going to get a chance to
take the story further so
congratulations on having such a great
success with the first one
that you got to make a second one
so we're going to meet a couple of the
people behind this film
the first is one of the co-directors
he uh recently graduated from film
school
or he had recently graduated from film
school
he's 90 years old now
i don't think that's right now when he
was hired to work as an animator on
ernest and celestine
yeah so we actually did just graduated
from film school ultimately becoming one
of the film's directors along with
vincent pattar and stefan albiere
this is his first nomination for
animated feature film please welcome
co-director benjamin rener
how you doing
so i'm gonna have some translation help
too you have to remind me of your name i
have already forgotten i'm sorry
when you come up
so this next person is the producer or
one of the producers of ernest and
celestine
he originally began working the film
industry as an assistant director and
later as a director of educational
documentary films before moving into
animation
in 1987 he founded trans-europe film
producing such animated features as
tales of the night
in 1994 he founded la amitire
whose productions have included the
animated feature nominees the triplets
of belleville
and the secret of kells
please give a warm welcome to didier
brunei the producer
tell me your name again i'm sorry
fred cassidy is going to help us talk
french
and christ
well
this is when i really start to fall
short
in the language department
so we were talking about earlier about
saving mr banks
go ahead you can translate i'll do small
chunks all right i'm sorry so and the
reason i bring it up is because that's a
story about a writer of a book who is
very reticent to have her film
made into some silly cartoon
and uh
and ultimately the animators triumphed
and apparently behind this story is a
similar story
although i'm sure she wasn't as
cantankerous
as
that woman
gabrielle vincent was the creator of the
books and she hadn't wanted a film
version to be made during her lifetime
and
you tried for 20 years to convince her
is that true
yes i tried to convince her and finally
she did
she died she died
and then
eight years later
the publisher
called me and say you want always the
right of the for the of the books of
gabrielle van gaal and i say of course
yes
and we did the film
eight years after the the
the days of
this great artist
that i
really respect
but
she
from when she was alive she was
completely
opposed
to the adaptation of his of her books
why why was she so opposed
was it because she was she since she
thought that
it was impossible to adapt her graphism
for for animation
the graphism is
the graphism of an illustrator very
simple and very sophisticated in the
same time
and
she was convinced that the cinema will
betrayed his graphism
and the
the style and the spirit of
her books
i'm sorry i try to speak english no no
no no i understand perfectly
well
congratulations on
overcoming her reticence even
though she never quite acquiesced
she acquiesced in an eternal kind of
cosmic way
no disrespect at all i can understand
that you know like someone spends their
life drawing and slaving over these
things and
it's understandable that you know she
wouldn't trust a character like you to
despite 20 years of pleading
but i have to say uh
i i did not know her books before i saw
the film but i thought the the film was
executed in a beautiful very um
very subtle and very uh
it had a simple purity to it and i think
she would have been proud
thank you very much
so benjamin you were one of three
directors on the film along with vincent
pattar and stefan obia
mercy
so what was that like working i think
i think we've only spoken to
co-directors
um
and that's usually a good cop bad cop
situation
how was it working with the three of you
um honestly it was really well the thing
was when i started working on the film
um i was not supposed to be the director
but uh one year after i started working
doesn't want to be the director i didn't
want to to be the director because i was
exiting school and i met this guy he
told me do you want to be the director
and i thought okay this guy is
completely crazy but he made good films
so he must be he must have good ideas
sometimes and
so i i told him okay but i need to have
a director with me and
as he's a very good uh co producer he
gave me two co-directors and it was
vincent pata and stefan obi they come as
a pair actually they are sort of couple
i mean they they work together all the
time and i don't know what they do in
private life but they're really nice
people
and and they made a very peculiar film
called a town called panic uh it's a
wonderful theme yeah for those who knows
and it's top machine film so we started
working together and we uh we realized
we have a passion for the film and
and
i was supposed to work on the artistic
part of the film and they were supposed
to to work on the narrative part of the
film
so but at some point we realized we had
to share everything together and we were
all very um modest people so we were not
like trying to
to impose anything to the other so we we
trusted each other so it was really
great i think
we are not here to tell what happened so
i can tell whatever i want
they're doing a q a in paris right now
where they're talking about what a
nightmare it was to work with you
so dda
dda i couldn't help but notice some
similarities to this rodent underworld
and another film that was recently very
popular an animated film called
ratatouille now
yes it was fine we're not talking about
that tonight but
it was very good i'm sure people
involved in are out there but the reason
i say that is because oftentimes in the
movie business
you'll be developing something and all
of a sudden something comes out that's
similar to it and then that's it they
pulled the money everyone said ah well
it's been done and
the sensitive sort of creative people
just get upset and they well i have to
do something else how did you get over
that and did it or did it even answer
your thinking uh the fact that
ratatouille had a similar
world at least for the rodents
the story of the
of the books was very simple and the
the point which excites me is
why a bear and a mouse could build
a such a complicity
they are
coming from two words completely
different the big bear the very small
mouth
and the mouth
is uh
this
uh
sorry
is an animal which is uh
unsupportable for for the bear because
in the film
she's told she
stole the the
the the teeth of of the of the of the
bears
for to
to repair
their teeth
i'm sorry i'm not very clear no no i
don't understand exactly what you mean
that was one of the that was
i mean
hats off to you for not even
acknowledging ratatouille and just
sticking to your guns
i would imagine after 20 years of trying
to convince this woman to do it you're
like [ __ ] ratatouille we're still making
it
just because the rats everyone knows
rats have an underworld we're still
making this story it's important
and in fact that was a really moving
thing i think i think human beings in
some way are just suckers for this
for this repeating story whether it's
romeo and juliet or west side story or
on and on and on this idea that
friendship and compassion for people or
creatures other than that are different
than yourself in the face of societal
condemnation and i i thought although
this is very sweet and and innocent
almost children's story that there are
some very powerful
uh themes at work that that share
that that are shared by things like
romeo and juliet were you thinking about
that as you were making it
is that why the book appealed to you in
the first place
what i'm sorry
i'm so sorry
no no i'm so sorry i'm so sorry my
favorite french word
i thought we were losing someone that
was laughing here so i was
just i don't know what happened to that
lady she's freaking out
so
translate exactly let's take a moment to
translate
me
okay
so this opposition of two worlds was the
very foundation and the spark that
really started the entire story and that
here you have two very different
creatures that in their own worlds in
their marginal they're marginalized and
so the the great improbability that they
would meet
and that they could even find a sense of
compatibility or friendship
was something that was uh exciting to
explore and also
since this is a film for children
this the message that this unlikely
friendship um carries
is
one of tolerance and of compassion and
friendship i really love that about this
film yes thank you
you know so so many of the films that
animated films that are made here in the
states they have this four quadrant
thing they're always going on about
where it has to appeal to little tiny
children has to appeal to
you know older kids and teenagers who
are smart asses and adults have to have
a few jokes too
i thought that was a really refreshing
and beautiful innocent thing about the
film that it has the gentle quality that
i i actually really enjoyed even though
my much younger child also
just was entranced by it so hats off to
sticking to your guns in that way can i
ask
are are
the books by this author very popular in
france
the book are very popular in france and
in belgium that's why we have a french
director and two belgium directors
they are
very popular but not
the the the author is dead so now
there's
no new books
so we decided in
to replace by a film
yes
i think we've established that she's
dead
benjamin
benjamin
did were you familiar with these books
as a child no i i didn't know anything
about the books uh before
before uh you better start making up
something for the press junkets
you did love them as a child yeah uh i
didn't have a chance to see them when i
was a child but i think to be honest i
think that was a good thing because i
had no pressure of nostalgia uh while i
was doing the the film and honestly when
i discovered the books it was like um
a strike i don't know uh you know when
you're struck in the heart or something
like this i don't know yeah you
understood struck in the heart
i was really blown away by the books and
i thought it was wonderful drawings and
and there was so much sensitivity in the
drawings and so much expression if you
have the opportunity of reading them
it's really wonderful there's one called
birth of celestine and it's one of the
most wonderful book i've ever read in my
life and to be honest the the last
picture in the film are the pictures
from this book so it can give you an
idea of the wonderful drawing she was
making so yeah it was uh it was just a
pleasure
having this drawing and putting it into
the animation the animation process was
it was it a process of deconstructing
the drawings of this person and moving
them because there there is a kind of
looseness to the to the drawing style
did you find yourself
trying to
actually take
this person's drawings and make them
move or did you or did you
wipe the slate a little more clear than
that and use the books as a story
inspiration um well i'm
at the very beginning i was not supposed
to work on the story so i was just
focusing on the drawing and i was taking
the illustration and just drawing them
and starting to make them move like make
them living
and
and i really wanted this sketchy looking
way of drawing and with these gaps and
just when you make a drawing and you
stop uh when you see it's it's working
when you you have your character is here
and you see the emotion he is expressing
and that's what we add for the direction
for the animation for over rest i really
wanted to everyone to have a pleasure of
drawing this way because it's more like
sketching more than making very precise
drawing very beautiful drawing want to
make very something very fast that's a
difficult thing to to try to
take on someone else's drawing style
that's a special challenge for an
animator i would imagine um one of the
things i really loved about the film was
how there's a purity to the to the
emotion of the story and there's a
purity to the way the characters speak
there's also a purity to the comic
uh physical uh stuff that happens i'm a
big laurel and hardy fan
and a lot of the kind of pratfalls
there's a lot of the movie that operates
in silence
without a lot of words and i thought
that was that was really
another level of purity was like the
gags you know the falling and the you
know
thank you
yeah we were i'm a big fan of harold
lloyd and
buster keaton and all this kind of humor
we tried to put
some of this in the film on yeah they
were americans those people by the way
yeah
um
but silence yeah
but they are good i mean so
oh yes
sorry
um i wanted to also mention that because
the next film we're going to look at is
by the great master miyazaki
and you you've mentioned
that you found his work to be an
inspiration
for your work
and seeing that you're just
relatively new like you want to talk
about that a little bit like what was
the first film of of his that that
struck you and what were the things that
formed your
young identity as an animator yeah
um my identity okay so let's talk about
that um i was
actually when i was young until i was 18
i was forbidden to watch any japanese
film because my parents were thinking it
was very violent and stuff so they are a
little prejudiced about that so when i
was 18 i was allowed to see my first
manga anime and it it was a spirited way
and
and
sorry i have to take my breath and um
and it was a really uh great story
a lot of emotion right now
i feel it too it was look
that film was a revelation to me as well
maybe you can talk about his identity i
don't know
thank you very much well i i love
miyazaki that's all i can say it's a
wonderful director and it's such an
honor to be
it must be a heady thing right
i have to say i really i really relate
to how you're feeling about it and that
way in terms of this whole oscar thing
that happens to you you're a young man
you come out of school someone says you
want to work on a movie
and all of a sudden you find yourself in
the company of a great master like
miyazaki and i you know i can really
relate to that can be it's a heady thing
but let me just say
soak it up kid
because these are the things that you
remember
as life goes on it's a very joyful time
even though it's
terribly
scary as it as it trundles along um
anyway i think that's a perfect time to
take a look at
our final clip of the evening thank you
so much for this film and for talking
with us tonight thank you
so
hayao miyazaki couldn't be here tonight
but i think he's earned the right to
stay home
his producers come here tonight to talk
to us about the wind rises
now this gentleman had enjoyed a long
career in magazine publishing when his
working relationship with filmmaker hayo
miyazaki began
after helping with the publication of
miyazaki's manga
nasika of the valley of the wind
and the resulting feature film version
he helped establish miyazaki's animation
production company called studio ghibli
he joined the company as a producer in
1989 and served as its president from
2005 to 2008
he continues as the company's managing
director and his films as a producer
include
princess mononoke
the aforementioned spirited away
and howl's moving castle
please welcome
the producer of the wind rises toshio
suzuki
you gonna join us
tell me late
miss what is your name
beth carey is going to help us translate
i tried to learn japanese
this week
did you learn anything
origato
good
we're off to a good start
so
toshio i understand miyazaki originally
wrote this story as a as a graphic novel
or a manga
and that you suggested it to him
to become a film
that's exactly right all right
so far so good randy
you studied a lot about the film i've
got it all right here um
so i have to say
when i read that i thought it was very
surprising because given the subject
matter um
the fact that the story is about a
designer of warplanes
for you know a terrible tragic war for
for the world
that the producer would be the one to
say
we should make this a movie
there goes our good start
a producer is somebody who sort of sits
at the sidelines and just comments and
pricks uh comments to the director
so it's best if
we
as producers
suggest
ideas that are troubling to the director
interesting
because a producer in america
is someone who tries to get the director
to avoid troubling ideas
ponyo
and he was talking about making part two
of ponyo a sequel to ponyo
and i didn't want to see a sequel to
ponyo
another huge difference between
producers
in japan and america
so when uh director miyazaki
was about was 70 years old he had his
first grandchild
he was born
and he
started thinking he wanted to make films
so that this grandchild could
see the films
and i think that that kind of of uh idea
behind making a film never goes well
so i wanted him to throw away that sense
that he wanted to do it for because he
had a gran a new grandchild and
to throw that idea away and to make a
different kind of film so you must have
a very strong relationship with miyazaki
to be able to say these difficult things
to them that's very impressive i would
be just
you know
bowing all the time and be just so
delighted
that to help him make whatever he wanted
to make
because it's true didn't he didn't you
know he himself was worried that the
film given its wartime subject matter
wouldn't appeal to younger audiences
but he has a lot of interest in war and
also in
war weapons
and airplanes that were used as weapons
but he considered his own interest in
his own personal hobby
and
had thought that he shouldn't make a
film just out of his own hobbies
so um he had
drawn a
graphic novel
manga novel of this
theme
but all the characters were pigs
so it was a bit of a of trying to make
fun of the situation as well huh
interesting
so do you think there was some type of
commentary you know he's used pigs
before
and spirited away when the parents
become pigs at the beginning of the film
um do you think he was saying something
about that when he when he made the
graphic novel was that some type of
comment on
on this
the people behin like was everyone in
the in the story pigs or was it the
people who were promoting war who were
pigs or
all the people in that uh mango were
pigs interesting
i want to just say
at this point i want to apologize for
the my goofy questions
i i i i feel compelled to say right now
what a profound impact these films have
had on me
um
and i i want
i want to thank you
and miyazaki for bringing so much beauty
into the world
thank you very much
um
so
i'm going to sound like an ignoramus
again and again i'm sure there are much
more eloquent people in the audience
that could speak to
the subtleties of the art
of these films but
like
benjamin i'd
we need a towel claire so sony
it's just water
it's okay
you've been baptized by hollywood
no no i'm sorry i did not mean to give
you an exploding water bottle
so was it was this a difficult subject
i've never been to japan
but i would imagine
if this was a story about
a german tank designer
there would be
somewhat of an anguished reaction from
the public in germany today so
what was that like presenting this film
to
the japanese public
foreign
so
from seeing the film you can obviously
see that he really loves german and
italian uh engineering and design and i
was wondering about that a little bit
myself but i just let him do what he
wanted to do yeah i'm sorry to get
bogged down in political ramifications
or audience reactions in fact i don't
think that
that matters a wit for art i think
you know i think the point
that the film makes and i think from
from some of these quotes i have
i think the origin the original
inspiration
miyazaki might have had was
he said
my wife and staff would ask me why make
a story about a man who made weapons of
war and i thought they were right but
one day i heard
horikoshi
once had said all i wanted to do was
make something beautiful
and if that's not a statement about a
filmmaker
that a filmmaker would make i don't know
what is um
there's no question in that statement
was a uh uh
real uh live person who lived and he was
known as the designer of the zero
fighter
and um mr miyazaki had thought that he
was misunderstood
um
in
the various interpretations
historically that had been made of him
and he wanted to um present
um the real what he felt was the real
jiro horikoshi as he must have been
so
to uh
kind of uh
for in in his on in to
make his honor
stand out and so um after the film was
uh uh released uh his son
mr horikoshi's son saw the the film and
was very glad that his uh father's honor
had been
reset
so and mr miyazaki was very happy to
hear that because that was one of his
intentions in making the film
yes
i think a lot of the geniuses who are
harnessed to war efforts across the
world are
are actually just that they're
honorable people who are geniuses at a
certain thing and
and the world takes them to war um
you know i wanted to talk a little bit
too about the actual art of of these
films and i'm
i'm definitely unqualified to be
discussing it but
um
you say you said that you know miyazaki
wanted to bring
forth
the the truth of this character and
there's something about
the animation style um
and i see it in almost all the films
this juxtaposition of lush almost
photographic but
but better than photographs
uh depictions of landscape
um
as a background in the scenes
and then then then the the people who
are are a much more traditional almost
two-dimensional uh animation style and
and yet somehow it's they seem more real
than than a photograph would be and i
wonder if that's something that you
discuss
um or it's something that just comes
from miyazaki he does on his own and
you witness it but do you ever discuss
these things and
i'm sure it's intentional the difference
between those two
styles of animation within the films
in making this film uh he uh and in
making all of his films and all of this
films in at studio ghibli we really pay
a lot of attention to the background art
and
he
obviously to make a beautiful
film and to make the background
beautiful and that's one of the very
important aspects of studio ghibli films
and he knew that there would be we would
be using a lot of airplanes in this film
warplanes uh so um mr miyazaki uh wanted
to
draw many many different kinds of clouds
at studio ghibli we have a building
that's a three-floor building and he
would come up to the third floor to the
top floor and look out at the landscape
especially near sunset time when the
clouds would be beautiful and sketch
those clouds in his mind
and then
he also told the background art
staff
to look at the paintings of the russian
painter
rematto
and that
those paintings were wonderful and that
they should
study them
to work on the clouds and the artwork
fantastic well i feel like we've just
scratched the
surface i could ask so many questions
about studio ghibli because
you know like benjamin said i i did not
have a bit of big
to japanese animation until i was an
adult i think maybe one of the only
things which i think may have been
drawn in japan was speed racer
that i watched as a kid
and so when i first saw spirited away
suddenly
it looked a little bit like speed racer
but
what's that it's
in japanese it's mesa
mach 555. mach 555 of course the mach 5.
um so anyway so so spirited away was
such a revelation because you had this
simple kind of you know i was
used to a certain simple
um visual information but then these
transformative things started happening
like pure magic was jumping out of the
screen
and i just have to say like suddenly i
was like where is the studio jeeply
it was like willy wonka's chocolate
factory
it was this mysterious place
how is it that they're able to produce
these beautiful things and i think if we
had more time i would love to discuss
the difference between
how organizationally and creatively and
the entire culture of stu studio jeebly
because it needs to be replicated
elsewhere in the world because it's
producing some of the most beautiful art
of our time
we're going to bring the rest of the
filmmakers up but um yeah so
stay here
you look very comfortable by the way i
love your style
very comfortable
although it's a little moist now but
so i'd like to ask everyone to come back
up on stage who we've spoken to tonight
we're going to add some chairs
i'm going to ask some sort of general
questions do i have a general yes i do i
do i do
come back up don't be shy i won't spill
water on you
i'm definitely getting a talk show out
of this
for sure three languages
come on
i have some general questions and if
there are any questions out there that
you have they better be good
because there's some
so don't just ask like
you know
what was the cage like
so what was nick cage like
now um so so we've we've
we've experienced three of the films
tonight with 3d goggles
and um
i want to know
and randy wants to know uh
did the decision to release the film in
3d influence the design of the film from
the beginning because a lot of films
i've noticed they kind of tack on like
oh we can add more screens if we
suddenly make it 3d uh of of your three
films the crudes despicable me 2 and
frozen was that part of the design
process from the very beginning or was
it something that you accommodated later
uh yeah well for us yeah we knew it was
going to be 3d from the beginning so yes
we did design things we did try to to
watch that we
didn't do a lot of the stuff flying at
you which people seem to
not be crazy about at least here in the
states and um so yeah we tried to
restrain ourselves a bit but we knew
from the beginning it was going to be 3d
so yeah it was made in parallel the
exact same time really along the way
croods well
you know
we i think we used to exercise more
restraint but one day i was getting my
hair cut and the girl who was cutting my
hair she was i was telling him about the
film and she's asking and i said oh man
you know we do all this 3d stuff but
we're trying to like you know we don't
want us to you know we don't want stuff
to just jump out at you and she was like
well that's what i pay for
and i was like you know maybe we should
do more of that
so in crudes we didn't really hold back
as much you know we just let it go a
little bit more but one of the cool
things about crude is we had these uh a
couple a couple uh moments where we had
the characters in the dark and we had
like uh fire light and these little
embers and stuff like that was a unique
moment to have these embers come out
into the um into the audience as far as
we could push them but the the theater
and the cave really became one because
the it became seamless you couldn't see
the edges of the screen it was just one
of those things you look for
opportunities like that we just got
lucky with a couple of those as
well how about you guys down there
despicable me too
i mean the initial promise of 3d was
[ __ ] jumps out at you
from the 1950s that was i think that was
the tagline on those movies [ __ ] jumps
out at you
and your your ass tingles
oh that was another that was tingle
vision
did you guys design the film with 3d you
must have yeah it was everything was
designed in 3d that doesn't mean
we particularly like 3d though
interesting neither do i
ah
i just find it i wish there was a way
they could do it without
the glass eyewear yes totally i feel
like there's a shield between me and the
experience but
i did love wreck-it ralph in 3-d
does anyone have a question before i ask
any more of my dumb questions does any
do any of you have a question for for
the the other filmmakers do you have
something you're wondering or have you
spent so much time
in cocktail parties together already
you have nothing to say to each other
anymore no okay
well think about it um how do you
approach this is for anyone who feels
like answering
how do you approach making a film that
is suitable for children yet can also be
enjoyed by adults or does that even
enter
your thinking i mean i know it does that
disney and dreamworks
but maybe not everyone
has that
these general questions are not going to
work because no one's gonna volunteer
jennifer go ahead i can say you know
when we work in wreck-it ralph i mean i
can only speak for ralph and frozen
you're conscious of it but we didn't
make any choices specifically saying we
need to make this simpler for children
or ever because kids get a lot more than
i think people think they do and and we
found that the most sophisticated themes
of the film the kids got right away
the adults tend to personalize it it's
it's all about their lives and and how
it speaks to them personally so as much
as we for entertainment value we like to
feel like we're reaching everyone at the
same time we feel like we don't want to
talk down to children so we don't really
ever you know say oh they won't get this
tashio can i ask you specifically
where do you see
um
where do you see animation going
next i know
miyazaki has announced his retirement
much to many people's chagrin
where do you see where do you see
it going from here especially with a
loss
like a filmmaker like miyazaki
foreign
my
so we at studio ghibli have been uh
making uh films for 30 years now
uh and during that time of course 3d uh
came came up uh but we decided not to
change what we had our way of doing
things into we decided to stick with the
2d and we would
bet on to keeping 2d
going
and the reason was that we felt that if
we shifted to 3d
there was no way that we could really
handle it and and
do a good job of it
so but now that um it's become the gener
the next generations of studio ghibli
if the younger generation
is interested in doing 3d then
maybe they'll do it and
mr miyazaki and i will look forward to
seeing what they come up with
well thank you
i like to do something corny but i know
each of you has this in your brain
um
i'd like to just go down the line from
that end and say and and just
sing
no you don't have to sing
unless yeah
um no just uh name one animated film
that
had like what is the earliest animated
film that in your experience that had an
impact on you
not so much that made you want to get
into animation but the first thing where
you went
the light went off like
this is an incredible art form
uh for me i think it was the jungle book
um because i i just i loved animals and
there they were all coming to life and
as i look back at it as an adult
um the vocal performances were just so
amazing they weren't actors i knew as a
kid but like the sheer khan and all
those different voice actors and coming
out of those beautifully drawn
characters that for me was the first one
that i really remember and still do yeah
damn you stole it from me
you can have the same
well it's that one plus
another one which really sort of opened
my eyes into
like those
trans
transversal thing that you were talking
about like
being making a movie animated movies for
that goes from children to
to adults uh particularly animated
movies which have a tendency like for
general public to be
you know people think it's mostly for
children
the movie that opened my eyes just for
that changed my mind on that is totoro
just
hope i didn't steal anyone so i hope i
stole your movie there
go ahead you have one
well actually he just stole mine because
uh
thanks a lot um i you know i didn't
watch any animation as a child growing
up i i
i had parents who were
uh avid film goers but you know i was
going to kubrick films when other people
were going to disney movies and just it
was going to ask if you were amish but
not if you went to kubrick
so um so i really started to watch
animation when i had my first son and uh
totoro was the
the very first film that
um
really ignited in me this uh passion for
animation
you can throw one in yeah it doesn't
matter
saturday morning cartoons that was
really
my favorite feed racers yes
george or the jungle all of the great
things while our parents were sleeping
sneaking yeah
did you
the first film i've seen when i was a
little little child is bambi from disney
and i was absolutely moved and
i think it's
the film which is
deep in my heart
and after that i discover of course the
japanese
animation through miyazaki and
especially poco
that i appreciated a lot
so that's my
and of course one one of my master also
it's more
cartoonist it's tech savory
which uh
i love those
those
those film because it's i like
cgi animation but i love
drawing design animated feature
based on
on the pain on the
painting
and the
hand drawn
animation
how about you benjamin
uh of course spirited away as you know
and but i must um one of the first film
that i was seeing when i was a child was
a film called the king of and the bird a
french film by paul grimo
and it was all um
i didn't realize until i was a teenager
that this film had a huge impact on my
on my way of drawing and everything and
i kept drawing
a boy and a girl running on the stairs
because they run a lot in stairs in the
king and the bird you have to see it's a
really beautiful theme if you haven't
seen it
and
yeah that's it that's a wonderful theme
and i was a big big big fan of donald
duck and i really love this character
i wish there will be a long future with
donald duck one day because i think he
deserves it
yeah
definitely
that's my audition for donald duck
toshio
what a dumb question that's what he said
i didn't actually watch much animation
when i was a child i used to like to
watch adult
films
that were made for adults and they
excited me because i i thought i
understood certain parts and and
we have a lot of exciting adult films
here in america i don't mean i don't
mean that i'm sorry not that kind of
but regular films
i probably did watch some animation but
i don't remember any and i never thought
that i would be a part of um uh
producing animation films
never in my life did i think that
how about you you know what for its
simplicity its honesty and its gutsiness
uh charlie brown christmas is still
my favorite
um
like some of the gentlemen who went
before me i also did not have the
opportunity to sell a lot of animation
um as a child and was exposed to it for
the first time watching with my kids
and like others before me it was totoro
and you know we've talked a lot or
you've talked a lot acknowledging the
visual beauty of the miyazaki movies and
they are breathtaking but i'd love to
give a shout out too to the music in the
movies the music and tutorial just
it just broke my heart it's just
incredible and my kids responded to it
immediately loved it i'd also like to
give a shout out to um spongebob that
was a big one
black i never had laughed that hard with
my kids it was it was it was it was
informative for me i i find it hard to
believe you didn't watch a lot of
animation because i come from a family
of six and i spent a lot of time in
front of the tv
and there was a lot of cartoons but you
must have had good parents my mom would
take the tv and put it in the trunk of
her car when she left the house so that
i couldn't see it wow i think she was
running away
but i probably said like strictly from
the raw power of the vocal performance i
would probably say wreck it ralph
oh come on
anyway
how about you jen
he just took mine
well i have to go back to the very first
one i saw and and first actually i got
the little book when i was two and it
was and then i saw the film a few years
later and it was cinderella
and i think from that moment on
i became like an escapist dreamer and
all i did was draw and write stories and
but you did a number on prince charming
and frozen though
life
dick
did you guys already answer this no
uh this film was already mentioned down
the line but for me the very first film
i saw was bambi and it was the humor of
uh thumper and bambi out on the ice
but also the emotion of the death of the
mother and i realized that that's what
there was something that hit my core
with that and as we make films i like
films that sort of have that range of
emotion i think it's important it's what
makes you feel that there you've been
watching a big film
i just have a question peter because the
other producers didn't watch cartoons as
kids
about you yeah but it was all yeah it
was all um
yeah i watched a lot of cartoons as kids
actually
it's just curious because okay so um uh
pinocchio pinocchio is mine and it was
not the original uh release
it was a re-release that i saw in the
theaters i'm not that old so um
but yeah i loved it loved it loved it
loved it loved the whole story loved the
thing loved monstro coming at me
remembered it and i think that was the
day that i said god i love animation so
does anyone have a question in the
audience that you just have to ask
all right there's three
that person that person and that person
those were the first three
um
is it on okay is there one special
experience or detail that will
especially be with you now that you've
made these films
from from the making of these films from
the meetings there's one special
audience reactions there yeah
everyone doesn't have to answer but if
anyone something sticks out like wow i
want to carry that with me
going forward
uh
we did uh a little thing on uh what was
it
reddit uh thing a few weeks ago and
there was this one last night
yeah yeah so it was fun um but we had
one you're going the internet and people
anyone can ask you anything in the whole
world you answer questions fyi
anyone over 40 out there
it's true
true thank you and one one woman wrote
in and and we had read a few things that
that watching frozen
at a bad time in her life had saved her
life and i don't think you know we could
do anything more than that so that is a
huge thing for us
very cool
does anyone else feel free to chime in
this gentleman right here you can just
say it to me and i'll repeat it oh no
here's a microphone it's your big chance
to sing pal
uh
i mean i could ask lots of questions but
uh just for the people who
worked on uh ernest and celestine i
wondered obviously you were you were
inspired by by the book and the and the
the beautiful illustrations and the
story but but you you made changes to
the design of the characters and to the
the story itself i would just be curious
you know
what made you decide to make
those change
did you initially intend to just
translate the books the way it was and
you know what made you decide to make
additions and changes and adjustments
i will try to answer
because i think
when you make an adaptation especially
when it's books
graphic books you make the adaptation of
the story but also also of the
drawings
and try to to keep
the
this
much of respect as possible
for the original
books but you are obliged to transform
the graphics just for
animation technically you cannot animate
the the graphism of
gabrielle vanson we is an illustrator
and has a graphism which is
sophisticated and
not done for animation
so we are obliged to find a way
to
between animation
and what was the graphism of the book
and
all the work of
benjamin
and the artist
designer
was to
adapt this graphism
but
to keep
the truth of this graphism
to keep the the spirit to to to be
as close as possible as of the original
graphism but
make uh
that
we have to make an animated feature and
so forth to transform these graphics
with uh
with with
the maximum speed
with maximum respect
yes
you understand french
so
my the detail which
moved to
the first detail
which moved me
when i see the
the first images of the film is when i
see
celestine
alive
under the
with the pen of benjamin
and which has not which was she was not
exactly the celestine of gabrielle
vanson but she was
in the spirit and in the style and in
the acting
what i imagine
if
gabrielle vanson has made this
herself this film
is
i think we
the the
our
principal uh
preoccupation was
to be
as close as possible of gabrielle vanson
and
and
enough
with enough
freedom liberty
of adaptation
to give
live
to this
graphism which was not done for
animation
i'm not sure i'm clear but
no i try to be perfect more
right i understand thank you
do you have anything to add benjamin i
think i'm good you covered that okay
so there's the last third the third
question whoever is the first person
here who did it was that you sir with
the hat it was
i think it was that person back there
was the first one who raised his hand
but
that's all right you're younger so
and you wore a tie
uh what i wanted to ask is the attention
to detail to lighting a scene
uh
things like uh how lighting falls onto a
character's face what are the
discussions that you guys had
lighting
that seems to be like a whole department
isn't it yeah yeah it's it's it's
if there's no light in the scene you
actually can't see anything it's it's
really fascinating to me as well one of
the people we partnered with was roger
deakins
on how to train your dragon and we were
looking for a particular look um because
it was such a fantastic story we wanted
the the weight of reality and we want a
little bit bolder look so one of the
things we did on how to train your
dragon is we were we we resisted the
impulse to put lights everywhere because
you can put lights wherever you want and
so i think i think personally there's a
lot of animation that's over lit
and uh because there's a table and you
want to see under the table and or like
you want to see like the eyes of a
character a little bit more you can
place a light
and
one of the things roger found
interesting and fascinating was that he
could place a light in a scene and you
don't actually see the light the rig but
you see the light hitting the characters
so you can put a light anywhere but we
really held back in hours um so there
are scenes in how to train your dragon
where the light just falls off and
things go into complete lack of detail
like complete blackness um so lighting
is i mean it's one of the most
incredible tools i think i think in in
cg animation the ability to move a
camera is gigantic it's one of the
biggest storytelling tools and one of
the other i think unsung heroes of this
whole thing is light i mean you can you
can you can make things feel unreal or
very real um depending on how you you
place them so it's an art unto itself
and one of the things we did
with frozen or was a different challenge
was because we had ice and snow
uh you're also dealing with a lot of
like refraction and reflecting light so
what what um our art director mike
giammo really did was amazing is you
know he said no nice you can go white
and blue and it's a blank canvas almost
so
we're going to use the lighting and
particularly the color and the palette
to tell the emotional story and
when we studied ice we started seeing
how much color there was and how much we
could use that to tell the story so yes
we'd always know where the sun is and
sort of use the lighting you know
accordingly as you would normally but in
addition to that we were
creating a style with it that we hadn't
done before there's still a lot of
cheating that goes on like you said well
we know where the sun is but there are
shots that
yeah you flip-flop a little bit and you
just say it just doesn't look that great
zoe you know whatever looks best for
that moment is what we try to do well
speaking of lighting i would like to
close on this thought
hearing each of you speak about the
films that that
inspired you
initially and
these things that lit this little candle
in your in your mind about animation
this is a flame that needs to be
protected from generation to generation
needs to be keep it needs to be kept lit
so on behalf of everyone here tonight
and on behalf of the whole world who
have enjoyed your films
first of all congratulations on your
oscar nominations
and second of all
second of all thank you so much for
keeping that little candle of
inspiration lit and i'm sure we'll be
talking about your films at a q a 20
years from now or longer thank you very
much stand up and take a bow please
thanks everybody